quand je me promène je suis aux aguets
et des ambiances avec les ciels la
lumière là c'est surtout ça je prends
une photo
montre qui je rends mon atelier je me
mets au travail
illico pour noter mon
impression j'ai eu la passion sentiment
ressenti de loire
[Musique]
on
encore
non
avoir un
à coups de couleurs de lignes verticales
et horizontales marque le coup trappe un
des moments de gloire le fleuve tel
qu'il le voit le matin de bonne heure le
soir au coucher du soleil et à tout
moment de l'année
avec cette loi qu'ils aiment tant est
qu'il côtoie depuis des années il a
tissé un lien profond je reçois des
contempteurs de la loi
parce que j'en helmand la loire elle
s'impose c'est une force c'était une
force à soi dans cette masse d'eau ça me
fait un peu subjugué par cette masse
d'eau qui coule comme ça
[Musique]
ce que j'ai voulu faire partager aux
gens c'est elle à ses paysages ses
instants une sélection des instants en
et fois être le ciel était âge ça bouge
très vite ça dure dix minutes
nombreux que par un ménage à
sa mine et a passé la main de l'artiste
a peint la loire dans toute sa diversité
à la fois changeantes puissante et
sauvage un bel hommage est une
invitation à la contempler
[Musique]